[Music]
he just jumped dance
sir but that opens a gate
Colten I have no idea where he went he
is gone you run after Colton why is that
such a big deal why is everybody
I can run I'm a human being I can run is
such a big deal I don't remember the
last time we saw you run on the show
would you ever see I usually don't have
to chase after anybody
but yeah usually I don't have to chase
but that's kind of the severity of where
we were that night and I have to kind of
really impress upon people where we were
in the middle of the Algarve region of
Portugal we truly lost them
so what emotions are going through your
mind and the producers minds because
yeah it's pitch black out there you
don't know if he has a phone money
anything how worried are you and how
scared are you for just his well-being
well as I told him I what do you Liam
Neeson you're gonna go to the embassy I
mean he said it why grab my wallet like
great that's gonna you don't have a
phone you'll have your passport where
are you going but he was just done and I
think that was the whole point is that
he finally thought he figured this whole
thing out and figured out that he loves
Cassie and this is it and then Cassie
realized his greatest fear and crushed
him and he just kind of broke and
snapped and he was done and I don't
think I realized the severity of it
until I was trying to walk after him and
obviously you saw the jump of the fence
and then he took off and then what
you'll see after this is kind of the raw
real emotions and it's not pretty it's
not pretty on my part it's not pretty on
the producers part or Colton's and I
think you're gonna see it warts and all
and it is really emotional and on all of
our parts a lot of tears were shed and a
lot of things were said that may not be
suitable for ABC but we all kind of
aired our grievances and let it all out
grievances with each other with Cole all
of it
Colton was upset and so you know I think
part of the blame he felt was on our
shoulders and part of it was his own and
part of it was just frustration because
of you know his pride and embarrassment
of thought he found the love his life
and it turned out he didn't and so they
just yeah there was just you know when
you run hot things are said okay I will
say we got em what you'll have to see
there was we all got emotional
and yeah I was emotional I won't say if
I cried or not you'll have to see but I
was emotional
[Music]